a decade ago a man in his 30s by the
name of Henry Rogers was one of 32 000
faculty members working in the State
University system of New York Henry was
an assistant professor making a modest
salary as he taught history classes to
undergraduates and wasn't exactly
lighting the academic world on fire but
he was doing pretty well all things
considered uh Henry had graduated from
high school with a GPA below 3.0 s.a.t
scores hovering around a thousand and
with numbers like that many students
decide to pass on College entirely for
good reason but here was Henry Rogers
teaching college students he wasn't
simply going to college he was educating
the Next Generation
so he was something of an unexpected
success story now nevertheless despite
the many blessings that were bestowed on
him by affirmative action Henry Rogers
dreamed bigger
you know he didn't want to be stuck at
SUNY forever he knew that if he wanted
to make a lot of money and advance in
Academia he needed a Rebrand you could
only go so far with a white sounding
name like Henry Rogers in the American
University system these days especially
in a state like New York so in 2013
Henry Rogers changed his name overnight
he became Ibrahim zolani Kennedy or
ibram X candy for sure and from that
point forward anyone looking at the CV
of this assistant professor at a
middling State School wouldn't
immediately think of someone boring and
generic and pasty instead they think of
black revolutionaries like Malcolm X
now looking back Henry rogers's name
change may go down as the single most
effective Rebrand in the history of this
country I mean his timing could have
been better at the moment uh Henry
Rogers transitioned into ibrahamex candy
corporate media in the U.S it just so
happened was was looking for something
to cover besides wealth inequality and
Occupy Wall Street they decided
apparently in concert to craft a
narrative that innocent young black
people were being hunted down by
deranged White supremacists to advance
that narrative the media lied about the
deaths of Trayvon Martin and Michael
Brown and eventually George Floyd and so
on and during this period they needed
Talking Heads with names like either Max
candy to tell Americans that their real
problem wasn't Citibank or JP Morgan it
was white people
one thing led to another and before you
knew it Henry Rogers was on the move he
was hired by American University in
Washington DC in 2017 which at the time
was struggling with the news that
bananas had been spotted hanging from
trees on campus this was presumed to be
a racist incident because why else would
there be bananas it must be racist and
Henry Rogers was going to fix things he
was going to fix everything specifically
Rogers promised to develop a racial
reporting guidebook and to conduct a
symposium on racial reporting
now none of that ever materialized and
this is a theme with Henry Rogers that
promises things and they don't actually
happen but even so Roger has received
tens of thousands of dollars in grant
money from places like the Ford
foundation and elsewhere to make it
happen
but Rogers was not completely idle
during this period after two years at
American University Henry produced a now
Infamous book called How To Be An
anti-racist which offered a novel Theory
Henry argued that the solution to racism
is more racism quote the only remedy to
racist discrimination is anti-racist
discrimination the only remedy to pass
discrimination is present discrimination
the only remedy to present
discrimination is future discrimination
now
if your IQ is higher than Henry Rogers
and unless you're a house cat it almost
certainly is that might seem
counter-intuitive in fact it might seem
like the single dumbest idea ever
committed to paper
but in 2019 this Theory this explicit
endorsement of racism of discrimination
lit the academic world on fire they were
thrilled by it that same year Henry
Rogers was invited to speak at the Aspen
ideas Festival where he had the
opportunity to expound on his ingenious
thesis before an audience of adoring
mostly white sycophants and yet despite
the friendly audience
things didn't go well and not to
oversell but this may be the single most
amusing clip to come out of the entire
Dei anti-racism craze and in case you
missed it at the time you're in for a
treat here is Henry Rogers AKA ibrahamex
candy explaining his definition of
racism or lack thereof
listen
I'm wondering I just finished reading
Robin D'Angelo's white fragility and I
think she did like an excellent job of
defining racism as like a system of
Oppression as opposed to like a personal
choice it's like it's there you benefit
from it or you don't that's its purpose
you talked about the importance of
defining racism but I but I unless I
missed it which is possible I didn't I
didn't hear your personal definition is
there is there one that you would offer
us like how do you define racism so
racism I would Define it
um as a collection
of racist policies that lead to racial
inequity that are substantiated by
racist ideas
[Laughter]
sure a collection of racist policies
that lead to racial inequity that are
substantiated by racist ideas
and anti-racism
is a pretty simple using the same terms
anti-racism is a collection of
anti-racist policies leading to racial
anybody want to take us Equity that are
substantiated by anti-racist ideas
thank you
um
thank you for this is the most
comprehensive talk I've seen on racism
in my whole life I really appreciate you
thank you for this this is the best that
was the most insightful thing I've ever
heard that was the greatest wisdom that
has ever been passed down in the history
of mankind
now this is an amazing clip for many
reasons for one thing even in the moment
with everyone in the room on Henry
rogers's side they're still nervous
laughter when he tries to articulate the
definition of the central concept
animating his entire life's work
even by the standards of woke up
academics this this was bad
and they all knew it
racism is when you're racist
well you know racism is when racist
things happen
okay thanks Henry that's very
Illuminating
everyone just smiles and nods awkwardly
because that's what Academia is now it's
a grift there's no Integrity there's no
dialogue there are no ideas that the
Aspen ideas Festival there's just
whatever that was
now this moment was not the end of Henry
rogers's academic career of course it
should have been
he's in the business of anti-racism and
can't tell you what it is
there's a lot of that sort of thing
going around on the left if you haven't
noticed
criticizing Henry Rogers though or
denying him promotions is white
supremacy so the promotions kept coming
Henry went on to spend a year as a
fellow at Harvard University after that
and then he received yet another
prestigious offer just weeks after
George Floyd's overdose Rogers was hired
to lead Boston University's Center for
anti-racist research and within weeks
massive donations were flowing in Jack
Dorsey the weird bearded founder of of
Twitter at the time donated 10 million
dollars to rogers's New Center lots of
money coming from lots of people random
companies like vertex Pharmaceuticals
contributed millions of dollars as well
in total the center raised well over 40
million dollars
to combat racism
and it's gonna be combated by a guy who
can't even tell you what it is
so where was all this money going
according to Boston University was going
to fund some really path-breaking
original research in the field of
anti-racism
in December of 2020 for example bu
published an article on his website
promising that Kendy would be bringing
anti-racist investigators together with
data scientists to tackle racial
inequities and to quote establish Boston
University as the nation's leading
academic Institution for data-driven
anti-racist research
you know with profiling surveillance and
data harvesting there are lots of things
not to like about tech Giants but what
can you actually do about it when you
rely on some of their many products we
don't all have 44 billion dollars to go
buying up Twitter and reform tech
companies from the inside ourselves with
the good news is you don't need to take
to be a billionaire to take a stand for
less than seven dollars per month you
can join me and fight back against big
Tech by using expressvpn how do you
think big tech companies make all their
money anyway well by tracking your
searches video history and everything
you click on and then selling your
personal data expressvpn helps you
anonymize much of your online presence
by hiding your IP address a unique
identifier that every device has that
allows big Tech to match your activity
back to you that's why I use expressvpn
on all my devices to make it much more
difficult for them to exploit my data
for their own purposes and the best part
is how easy it is to use the expressvpn
app I just have one button on my phone
or computer to turn it on and that's all
it takes to keep people out of my
business so if you don't like big Tech
tracking you and selling your personal
data for profit it's time time to fight
back get expressvpn right now to protect
your online freedom and privacy and get
three extra months for free by using my
Link at expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show
well what came of this unprecedented
collaboration between rogers's
anti-racist experts and bu's data
scientists where racial inequities
tackled
not quite
the Washington Free Beacon looked into
this and they found that Kennedy's
anti-racist Center established something
called the racial data lab which is now
completely defunct quote as of September
the racial data lab only compiled
information on covid-19 infections and
deaths the kova 19 tracker stopped
collecting information in March 2021 the
center has since removed the names of
anyone who worked on that project from
its website
so they compiled information from a
bunch of other sources about coveted
deaths
and then they stopped after about a year
that's it
now we did reach out to Boston
University to see if there was something
we were missing
but they didn't reply so it's clear that
the sum total of bu's Big anti-racism
Data initiative the one they touted with
articles and a lot of marketing
materials
was this this was it this little covid
tracker that's all they did
not to be fair in its three years of
existence Rogers is anti-racist Center
also managed to take other steps towards
anti-racism so for example Scholars at
the center managed to produce not one
but two two published papers in three
years two whole papers
for 40 million dollars it's not bad
that's 20 million a piece
one of these papers looked at Google
Street View images and concluded based
on that that neighborhoods with mostly
black residents have more dilapidated
buildings than neighborhoods with mostly
white residents
I mean this is groundbreaking shocking
stuff no one knew that until they they
spent millions of dollars studying that
and then and then someone's a light bulb
moment one of the the researchers said
hey get over here look at this
according to what I'm discovering inner
city communities have a lot of buildings
that are in bad shape
Dear God
now for his part Kendy had some bright
ideas that he occasionally shared with
media outlets in this country for
example he told political quote
to fix the original sin of racism
Americans should pass an anti-racist
amendment to the U.S Constitution the
amendment would make unconstitutional
racial inequity uh over a certain
threshold as as well as racist ideas by
public officials it would establish and
permanently fund the department of
anti-racism DOA comprised of formally
trained experts on racism and no
political appointees the DOA would be
responsible for a pre-clearing all local
state and federal public policies to
ensure that they won't yield racial
inequity
so imagine spending millions of dollars
investing in a research center written
by someone who sincerely believes
something like that
is a good idea
I mean it's so unbelievably degrading so
stupid that it defies analysis really
what would you tell your shareholders
what would you tell yourself when you
look at yourself in the mirror
is there literally anyone on the planet
who thinks a department of anti-racism
literally the acronym is DOA Dead on
Arrival
would be a good idea
well maybe if you're one of rogers's
investors you'd hold out hope that
sooner or later the scholars in this
prestigious anti-racism Center are
eventually going to buckle down and get
to work and produce something that's
actually useful
but if you thought that you would be
wrong and that's now very clear this
week we learned that Kennedy's
anti-racist Center has just fired more
than half of its staff
they've apparently
managed to burn through uh much of the
40 million dollars they've raised and to
be clear
this is an operation that that does not
involve particle colliders or expensive
equipments okay this is a bunch of
anti-racist experts sitting around
telling white people that they're
terrible
and whatever else you want to say about
work like that you would think at least
it would be cheap
but they managed to blow through 40
million dollars in three years doing
that
and now at long last Boston University
says that it's opened an inquiry into
where all this money went exactly
if we're being honest Federal
prosecutors should also be doing an
inquiry about that same subject but of
course we know that they won't because
Henry Rogers is doing their bidding
now at this point it would be easy to
gloat
you know gloating over the aftermath of
the complete and total implosion of this
whole project and we should gloat a
little bit because it's hilarious and
everyone who got screwed out of their
money deserved it
um there's the fact that one of rogers's
former staffers called these layoffs an
example of employment violence and
systemic racism which is pretty funny
many observers have made the point that
the woke inevitably eat their own and
that's true for the most part you get a
bunch of professional whiners into one
room get a bunch of professional victims
into one room give them 40 million bucks
and pretty soon they're going to be out
of money and still complaining
in case that's not obvious Henry Rogers
just proved that point so
so what's going on here why did his
anti-racist Center really collapse was
it just mismanagement is this an
isolated incident confined to Boston
University
that's possible but if you look at
broader Trends it seems like something
else is afoot here it seems like all
over the country major institutions are
ditching the Dei scammers it's not just
happening in Boston according to one
recent analysis job postings for Di
positions fell by roughly 20 last year
the average tenure of senior Dei
Executives at uh Fortune 500 companies
hired since 2018 has been less than two
years
that's according to a consulting firm
that specializes in this area BLM
meanwhile is in the red as of last
fiscal year they're bleeding cast
they're burning through cash and a lot
of it they wasted on mansions in
California apparently so seeing all this
it's tempting to say
that the whole anti-racism scam is
collapsing
but as welcoming a development as that
would be I think we have to resist the
temptation to come to that conclusion I
don't think that's exactly what's
Happening Here
as we've all learned over the past 10
years the race hustle is far too useful
and far too profitable to the people in
power
and multiple generations of Americans
have been too thoroughly indoctrinated
into this millions of black Americans
really do believe that they are
Perpetual victims while millions of
whites really do see themselves as
guilty of imaginary racial sins
just because Henry Rogers and a lot of
his imitators have been exposed doesn't
mean that the underlying ideology has
been defeated
these charlatans are low-hanging fruit
they're grunts that are easily
replaceable and you know eventually
they're all going to self-immolate
because they're a bunch of cheap con
artists and that's what cheap con
artists do
but still you have to think about how
quickly these grifters took control of
every major cultural and political
institution
we went from don't judge people based on
the color of their skin to
discrimination is anti-racist in a very
short period of time
feels like it happened overnight
okay like the Protestant Reformation
took a lot longer to get going if only
because people were communicating by
horse or shit-borne letters or whatever
the woke social credit Equity
biosurveillance state
uh that Reformation uh took hold much
faster
and they can Elevate con artists like
Henry Rogers so quickly that we don't
know what's happening until they've got
40 million dollars in control of major
institutions
they can scam the most sophisticated
investors on the planet
allegedly from Tech Executives to Big
Pharma
Henry Rogers and his team they haven't
done much in their tenure is highly paid
anti-racist activists but they have
demonstrated one thing albeit
inadvertently
and that's the fact that there isn't any
substance to so-called anti-racist
ideology it's just Mega corporations
looking to give big payouts to the first
guy they find with an exotic name
if it's not fraud it's something very
close to it
if the right can finally admit that
instead of playing along with these
charlatans and funding the universities
that promote this garbage
then things can change very quickly
but if we can't take those steps then
nothing will change at all
if we continue to tolerate this
then no matter what happens to Henry
Rogers we can look forward to many more
ibram X Kennedys down the line
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed